aquí
[Música]
experto aficionado fraude artistas del
tatuaje
yo soy motoki y esto es experto
aficionado fraude e intentaremos
averiguar quién es el experto y quién es
un fraude vamos a entrevistar a tres
artistas
bien tienes tatuajes no tengo ningún
tatuaje tampoco yo bien
haremos un cambio en el episodio de hoy
hola hola pues bien a quien ustedes
consideren es el experto que va a
tatuarme no puede ser
interesante verdad tienes mucha presión
ahora
pero lo hacemos tonterías y decimos
cosas sin sentido confío en que tomarán
la decisión correcta
no deberías
[Música]
hola
muchas gracias por recibirnos
bienvenidos como te cruzas baila un
placer conoce y conocida como blog lees
en el mundo del tatuaje estas son
máquinas de bobinas quizás sean las
máquinas más populares de la vieja
escuela reciben este nombre porque estas
máquinas tienen estas dos bobinas que
pueden ver aquí esta es la bobina
delantera y esta es la trasera y estas
son tintas y también agujas que no vamos
a abrir porque esto no es un
establecimiento con licencia y no está
actuaremos en la decisión
la razón por la que me gusta tatuar es
porque siempre quise encontrar una
carrera en la que demostrar mis talentos
tienes muchos tatuajes veo muchos
lugares de algo esto significa
crepúsculo y amanecer y esto es de livin
on a prayer la canción de bon jovi un
hombre lobo y también una luna ante esto
el seguro de tus tatuajes no yo no no me
agrada la idea de hacerme yo misma mis
tatuajes solo porque estoy segura de que
si lo hago algún día podría arrepentirme
por eso prefiero que lo haga
bueno yo también soy una profesional
pero prefiero que lo haga alguien de
quien coleccionó arte comprendo muy bien
qué opinas de shaila no sé tengo la
sensación de que está aquí para
despistarnos no sé un tatuaje en el
rostro la mayoría de la gente ha
reconocido que en el rostro quizás sean
artistas del tatuaje de que hables si es
razón
vayamos a conocerlos igualmente tengo
una impresora de plantillas y tinta me
dio un poco de pereza no quería traer
todas mis cosas hoy entonces primero
imprime es lo que vas si interminable
guardia sí y luego luego pongo la
plantilla sobre en la piel del cliente y
al quitarla me aseguro de que todo se
haya transferido a la piel y entonces es
cuando empiezo a tatuar tienes unos
tatuajes recientes esta noche la verdad
no puedes parar son muy efectivos y se
siente liberador también siendo honesta
cual es la petición más extraña que has
recibido de un cliente en el pasado la
mayoría de las veces la gente me pedía
palabras y frases y no las aceptaba
porque no es mi estilo sé que no es nada
extraño pero es algo que rechazó porque
no es un tatuaje en el que pondré mi
corazón no será una pieza especial para
ellos estoy de acuerdo si estás haciendo
algo que no te gusta mucho con esa
energía este en el tatuaje englaro
lo siento
pero solo tinta negra no trabaja con
otros colores no sólo trabaja sino lo
negro es esto es ni lo dice ni sabía que
vendría hoy aquí creen que era parte de
su plan decir si son nuevos quiero
confiar en ella y pensar que se hizo sus
tatuajes pero si lo hizo son muy ella es
una gran artista además tiene esto que
quizás sea de un amigo y éste lo tomó
prestado de clase después de que sea una
artista fraudulento va a tener alguna de
estas conocer que se los haya dado la
producción
ustedes harían algo así explicó patas
cómo te llamas mi nombre es cristian un
gusto conocerte cristian que tienes ahí
esto es una máquina rotativa ya que
ambos tienen los guantes puestos
presentarle un vicioso es sólo una
no comprendo por cuál lado está
parece un consolador
no sé qué le ocurre lo siento me siento
una señora vez mis bromas los viejos no
dicen consolador
algo que te negaría a hacer en absoluto
algo quizás algo como que te pareciera
moralmente incorrecto de hacer quizá los
genitales escribiendo pero hablas de
tatuar genitales o tatuar los genitales
de la gente sí sí
está vigente y dos personas llegan no sé
si alguna vez te ha pasado y dicen nos
acabamos de conocer estamos enamorados
que si los cuernos del nombre del otro
salgo de la habitación me río y luego
vuelvo y les digo de acuerdo lo haré
claro pero hago un pequeño tatuaje para
que cuando decidan que quieren cumplir
lo sea un trabajo fácil de hacer claro
muchos tatuajes y
todo lo contrario a mí tienes muy claro
un trabajo estresante así que es bueno
estar tranquilo mantener la calma porque
tratas con mucha gente cómo está tu auto
durante tantos años he aprendido a estar
en una especie de estado zen con solo
respirar y pensar en el ahora quiero ver
algunos de tus tatuajes se ven
interesándose poco removía algunos de
ellos de mis manos son muchas cosas de
películas star wars y no me gusta ni
existe alguno tú mismo no nunca me
tocaría con una mano genial bien creo
que cualquiera puede responder esto los
tatuajes son una especie de tabú en la
sociedad en general en especial los que
son muy visibles como los tatuajes en el
rostro como tu luna y algunos otros que
has visto que le dirían a esa que no es
mi problema no es muy simple más
en ocasiones la gente te discrimina por
tener tatuajes visibles o hacen
suposiciones de que estuviste en prisión
pero hace mucho tiempo la gente solía
tatuarse solo para reconocer de qué
tribu era por supuesto si deberías
hablar con mi madre
asiática también lo lleva el tema de los
tatuajes pero le dije lo siento ni nada
muchas gracias a todos ha sido un placer
hablar con ustedes y conocerlos y si
bendición
te has hecho un tatuaje antes y algunos
de ellos te dio como la vibra de que era
un artista del tatuaje percibiste eso
pues si esto no ayudará porque todos lo
hicieron por lo general son personas muy
tranquilas y relajadas y todos ellos se
comportaron a cien
empecemos con el experto por instinto
a321
como ya les dije es muy centrado cierto
te sientes en calma si es así cuando
pienso en él como un artista del tatuaje
lo imagino muy tranquilo diciendo oye
solo déjame poner esta casa cierto amigo
junto que tiffany y cristian tenían más
de esa vibra es que sayles el fraude
entonces crees que eso es lo que iba a
decir también que piensas tu hija shaila
como la experta de verdad por la máquina
de la vieja escuela comprendo vi un
vídeo de youtube sobre un espía que
hablaba de cómo detectar a un mentiroso
y la única persona que parecía estar
distante y no tenía esa vibra era
tiffany para mí así hay unas cosas que
vi en ese vídeo de asia
hablo de todo el proceso de hacer
plantillas y habló sobre el estilo de
tatuarse que no le gusta hacer lo que es
bastante probable eso es interesante y
quizás shaila no es un fraude
habló sobre como la gente piensa que si
tienes tatuajes significa que en
esa escuela quizás shaila sea una amante
de los tatuajes y una gran defensora de
los mismos pero eso no significa que sea
una artista eso es increíble no puede
ser que hace dos minutos pensaba que
bailara la puerta
todavía estoy emocionada pero un poco
nerviosa ahora es real está a punto de
suceder ahora vamos a invitar aquí a
nuestros artistas del tatuaje son y
orgullosos bienvenidos chicos fue una
decisión muy difícil para ser honesta sé
que pueden pensar que decimos esto
siempre pero nos tomó más de una hora de
liberar shaila
creemos que es un fraude
pensamos que sabes mucho sobre tatuajes
y además tienes unos tatuajes increíbles
pero pensamos que quizás estabas
hablando de ello de una manera para
quizás intentar engañarnos querés
demonios
más bien brilla xix es sólo uno menos
podría ser la visión es importante y
fanny cómo estás
pensamos que eres la afición afición
parece saber mucho sobre el mundo del
tatuaje pareces tener clientes si los
ejemplos que mencionaste sobre yo sería
clientes sí pero tal vez es más como un
negocio secundario no lo sé eso es mi
conclusión más tranquila y calmada pero
quizás no haces esto a tiempo completo
lo más probable es que estemos
equivocados pero eres
1a
qué significa
esto es aterrador en el mejor de los
casos
cristian no es el fraude sí muy bien lo
que vamos a hacer es
cristian tendrás que tatuar a bridget
antes de saber que antes de saberlo
bien
brilla
cómo te sientes
después
ahora
estás bromeando pues tienes las
herramientas que trajiste y yo sus
herramientas no pensé en esos dos
propuestas estoy bien muy bien eso es
bueno es una buena noticia que los dos
estamos muy bien ahora por ahora sí más
tarde espero podría estar bien
agua
bien
como estas si
lo hago todo el tiempo
bien
espera antes de empezar están seguros
quieren hacer actitud espera que el
fraude estaba por comenzar a hacer un
tatuaje yo estaría muy preocupada por la
contaminación por patógenos transmitidos
por la sangre y también por saber si esa
persona sabe cómo manejar una máquina de
tatuar y es el momento
[Risas]
estoy lista voy a empezar
y el primer trazo
y la piel
eso es mirar eso lo hizo
esta línea
activa como están chicos mi corazón va
explosivo y comprendo
haces bien las líneas
al crecer quería ser artista pero no
sabía qué camino tomar para llegar a eso
mi hermana empezó a involucrarse en el
mundo del tatuaje y me invitó a abrir
una tienda con ella eso hice empecé a
tatuar y descubrí que era lo mejor para
mí entonces eres la aficionada de hecho
soy aprendiz desde hace dos años como
tuve que mudarme a riverside aún no
tengo claro si abrir en mi propia tienda
o si continuaré mi aprendizaje eso es
increíble
lo que dije pero creo fraude porque eres
calmada además tus tatuajes pero soy
mucho parecías muy serio tuve 10 horas
con una artista del tatuaje ayer
escuchando la historia de su vida a
fondo utilizarla y poder decirla hoy eso
fue lo que dije recuerdas que dije que
tal vez sus nuevos tatuajes los hizo
para venir hoy aquí presumirlos
yo sólo quería alguno más así que me
distingo ayer la verdad empecé a hacerme
tatuajes está
hace como seis meses y ya tengo 20 como
estás brigitte te sientes bien me siento
muy bien estoy muy orgullosa de todos
nosotros
esto es genial gracias a todos por mirar
ya me siento mucho mejor también yo y la
verdad fue muy muy estresante estaba
sintiendo ansiosa y estaba preocupada
pensando que hemos hecho queremos leer
sus comentarios lo que pensaban ya lo
sabían estaban preocupados
[Música]